I guess the most important question is
when did you decide to sign this
exclusive Disney contract hey I would
love to do that I love working at Disney
they are the best they're confident they
cut they let you carve out new space for
yourself they don't micromanage I'm into
them and what I'm all-in on Disney who
just ended you were 20 I'm telling you
I'm all-in
I tell Alan Alan horn and Sean Bailey
all the time I'm all-in I love them were
you more nervous to film the sequence
where you're coming down in the in the
you know the umbrella yeah or signing on
to this movie oh the umbrella for sure
because that's just a physical thing
that takes over you where you think this
is it I could die playing Mary Poppins
this could be how I go you know signing
on to it was me because I was a bit
stunned I didn't quite absorb it in the
magnitude that it probably was but Rob
Marshall is the most embalming person in
the world you sort of could fly without
an umbrella during the Rob Marshall and
he made sure everything felt beautiful
exquisitely intimate and that I was
capable of doing this and there was no
one else who could play this role he
said stuff to you like that and you're
like you know what I believe you I will
believe anything that comes out of your
mouth I am curious though with the
umbrella thing how does that get
presented to you it's he does he pull
you aside like the day before and say so
we're gonna do this sequence
don't be nervous no we will realize
Rob's greatest gift we call him the
sweet assassin because he's so wonderful
and he approaches you with this like
beautiful smile and he says okay so
honey this is what we're gonna do you're
gonna be 60 feet in the air
it's so exciting right so exciting and
you're gonna come all the way down and
walk straight into your close-up but
it's gonna be so fabulous I look so
beautiful
you know and you just do it because you
don't want to let him down you can't
bear the thought of letting him down
they always say in movies don't work
with animals and don't work with kids
yeah the kids in this movie are
phenomenal aren't they phenomenal I know
they're exquisite this doesn't make
sense
Sebby on
yes so when did you first what was it
like meeting them for the first time or
just seeing their work because they're
so good well they are so brilliant and I
got to really bond with them and get to
know them over the nine weeks of
rehearsal and they were just they're
delightful and radiant and very
different personalities you know pixie
who plays Annabelle is such a pro I mean
she's probably worked more than any of
us put together she's just so she's the
perfect child and Nathaniel who plays
her twin he he's very capable of
anything and observant and just could do
anything that was asked of him and joel
is the blonde one who was completely out
of his mind and was sort of been
bouncing off the walls but yet because
he's never done a film before he has no
technique whatsoever he was sort of
wonderful when you put the camera on him
because he was so spontaneous sure so
cool I definitely want to talk about the
underwater stuff what is it like
actually filming that and you know talk
a little bit about the technical stuff
that goes on in making something like
that well that was all green-screen were
on wires sort of hung horizontal and you
have to kind of pretend to be swimming
so a lot of these sort of arm movements
and then what they do is they play the
music at double speed so that when so
you have to sing at double speed which
is a bit embarrassing because you sound
a bit like alvin and the chipmunks
but then what they do is when they when
they put it all together they can slow
you down or something so that it looks
like you're floating it looks like your
body's floating but your lips are moving
at the right time with the music does
that make sense it doesn't it's crazy
very untechnical so I don't know it's
just madness I just did what I was told
and it seemed to have worked out yes
you